what is happening reject nation it is
Greg Alva and John Humphrey here so the
out studios vol 1 yeah we finally got it
guys it just came out today zygote the
one we've been prepping for it's in the
anthology series people been asking us
to check these out as I go came out
today it's the first one were on top of
yes it's a new and do it the latest off
of it yeah sorry oh wait Dakota Fanning
and Jose Pablo Cantillo John look we
mentioned this in our first three
reactions because this is the fourth one
for ode studios but really quick
watching them break down without studios
is okay so Otzi rios in an experimental
film lab you might know the name neill
blomkamp is the guy of may in district 9
at least IAM chappie this is his new
project an independent studio with the
capacity to do pretty much all of the
aspects of film production from start to
finish and they're making these crazy
experimental sci-fi films and they
operate on an open source format which
allows you know you us the fans to get
involved with the filmmakers even go so
far as to download assets and things
from the films themselves to engage your
own creativity and eventually I guess
they want to turn some of these you know
stories that they're coming up with into
feature films and series and stuff like
that and they're airing these short
films for free on YouTube on their
Facebook page and on Steam as well in
fact if you want to get involved if you
want to support if you believe in what
out Studios is doing I think for each of
these films for like $4.99 you can go on
there and download behind the scenes
content dailies sound stems the scores
and stuff you can the 3d models like you
can really get creative if you want to
this is a huge like a really bitchin
project yeah man I'm excited to see this
because I really did love the first
three especially the first two second
one and my favorite so far let's get
into this one let's do this I goat man
let's do the zygote
I know it's I go means zygote is when
it's when sperm enters an egg and it's
that thing it's it's the Union yeah life
I know this kind now this guy knows I
play a character called a zygote stone
in a high school short we made one not
as experimental and actually lose
we go
[Music]
car doors mining operation Arctic Circle
ABP negate survivors teeth to that red
light helps back there she is
[Music]
this is aliens health
[Music]
[Music]
how would you sleep ever
maybe a day's worth very low on water
stick sticks to resume gone NMR you eat
to come first
I was born sadhana class white reflector
you don't [ __ ] spell used to dance
only difference losing your mind and
[ __ ]
if you dare yourself find something for
killing all these people
we make it build up into the cottage
shelter for the main course which is
really wanna be there about the stances
we have the classic corporate one
[Music]
arrogance or southbound vibe to the
whole of their sensations in trips or
forces once you live near chair for that
right there all of the stairs for the
Prince Francis here will diverse
variable freestanding intentions down
guys first was in those boxes
it knows everything like a baby doesn't
like it yeah Jesus
you gotta get across to the second
facility you're condemning class right
to see chronically good canary class
will give access to firearms with the
Bionic school around like they're
talking right before times long way if
you got the [ __ ] gun pull back okay
bring it do it rabbit :
yes now it's ready to fire it's gonna
pick when you fire no more than the
pneumatic drills are Houston's
normally surprised now she's like dead
[ __ ] put the gun down
bear with me
[Music]
Humana 60 round hi my penis with
explosive round battle you got back gets
a granite the Guru didn't Elston worry
so much red and only conversation so you
know you can once things over and forty
five persons inside just walking free so
bossy nobody does
come on that'd be one of them and it
goes wrong it sucks it went way they
went on that night
oh that's me
[Music]
come on ooh I couldn't
[Music]
camera director heir to an alien
pleasure the music give to me or to
reminisce now when we open that door we
got about a hundred meters to go in the
technically identify all measures to get
through it's coming what I want you to
do you ain't straight
you ain't straight you [ __ ] hear me
you see here right oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
straight team strength
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe Mary to come back to the gorgeous
music scene later
[Music]
whoa that is really disturbing would
being almost the weirder yeah like a
diamond yeah
[Music]
Oh your magaz one-month jamak jamak
[Music]
stamp camera has cutter
[Music]
let's go whoa those magazines don't last
long oh my god there it is 3000 boy with
me Chile boom that all anybody how much
there you go take the gun 600 we're
still close
I'm [ __ ] so the world turns I can see
something wrong stage a projected budget
my biscuit bullet damage in barracks
must be used as my Jamaica protocol
seven statute nine with you how much two
things cost the overhead involved today
because more than purchase uses
stratigraphy by you to result in a
[ __ ] human boggling at or covetous
for the oceans better mark of mrs. wall
you can assign evil which are John a
John is the golden my chance against me
asteroids heat your job is to die if you
walk into a pocket with a ghastly then
you mean especially if they click done
do you think it needs ability what about
this place but you know who you are but
the courts are flashing jihad yes the
computers are gonna reject is that it
could be the pinky there I remember but
this thing it gets to be a musician
[Music]
you heard her finger olive man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the name for that creature
[Music]
[Music]
and where's your head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
really helps you survive
I'm gonna really help you oh snap
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's just really what I'm walking on
yeah that's exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
giving me
uh yeah I would watch chance right
just done that from the beginning
oh you don't want to go on it either
ball you're out something sure
turn around yeah go to town yep go to
town still the top two in the chest and
one in the head go to town just trying
to get a hand back to the door I mean it
would probably take hours oh so
critically in vengeance it's a massive
version of having way too many keys
riding z1000 coming back people
[Music]
I'll take that Hamlet
oh darn I made it everything's gonna be
Kevin that position listen yeah yeah
yeah good no longer have to live in here
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
really tight and these man they think
they really know how to end these at the
exact time you'll and who know why yeah
well boy whoa man that was uh I was
nerve that know that that is probably
the best one I think that's my favorite
so far
there was a voting poll of which one
should be made into a movie easily this
one oh yeah easily I feel like firebase
would be a cool show and so what Rakha
this one I'm like I feel like this is a
scene from this as Kentucky like yes I
go to the full feature film script and
they took like 20 minutes of it and yeah
and put it on it and shot that because
you got a whole back there's like detail
to the backstory that they're obviously
hinting at the entire time you know
these two characters have a huge
backstory there and you can imagine the
whole adventure took place to this like
you pointed out the thing yeah I imagine
that's how it's like it just slowly
grows bigger and bigger from consuming
other human body parts over time the
multiple Idol a hand that was that was
super creepy especially in the first
half of it I was getting like a
terminator a terminator 2 by an aliens
vibe and the way it was lit the way it
was shot the tone I felt like Dakota
Fanning's character was like a hybrid of
like Ripley Sarah Connor and me
yeah and I kind of felt like I have a
guy was a little bit like Sarah Connor
meets Michael Biehn from aliens X yeah
that was wonderfully shot wildly intense
oh my god this yeah this one I think of
all of them is the most just outright
intense yeah you guys suck through the
reaction like have the time I blew you
know one of these has generated a
different kind of reaction yeah they
they said they set out to make you know
a bunch of compelling genera and and
that's the word I can use for all of
them really like each one has been
compelling in its own way and this one
yeah I think might be my favorite so far
just for how immediate and
claustrophobic and just and the creature
Narellan ability yeah appreciatively is
brilliant I love I wonder what the name
is with maybe the creatures calls I go
that's my guess because that creature
was insanely creative the multiple hands
the eyes the way it creates is giant
morphing crease of body horror creature
and even in act a little touch of the
year talking about like the word like
the best version of having too many keys
with the hands I love that little like
practical effect that's a human Avengers
to choose even if like I thought of the
thing right when I saw it but like you
behold the whole creature and somehow
even though the idea is similar to yeah
a massive parts and bits it looks all at
all it's only around who this reminds me
I had a I had a toy as a child that was
like a ball made of fingers okay she's
like outward pointing fingers and
imagine how weird that sounds and now
imagine that as a monster yeah with more
than just fingers and that's what that
is and I and I again I I like that we're
also scaling down into something that's
just about two characters isolated
there's nobody else you know and you're
catching details I like sci-fi when
you're catching details about the world
kind of through dialogue and you're
going yeah I found myself sometimes I'm
going to look down and really pay
attention to what he was saying yeah I
got to catch this because there's so
many there's so much that's what I mean
by how I felt like there's a much bigger
script at play here and they took like a
20 minute they took twenty minutes out
of that and shot that because this feels
like a scene from a feature film the
other ones feel like short films this
one feels like a four
on sequence in the finale from a feature
film I know they want they were hoping
like maybe at least one of these can get
turned into a feature film I'm really
hoping it's this one of those Emily
could get greenlit it's very immediate
it's reminiscent of 80s horror sci-fi
which I really did appreciate it and
going back to why and I don't want to
keep comparing it but I was thinking
about aliens too in terms of the
environment they were in it's like
aliens and the thing in terms of the
environment there and then they go
outside it's all snowy and you don't
want to be outside because it's dark and
dangerous it is not just running - yeah
no he can't see anything
snow everywhere at the reveal of the
hands like the way it was lit with oh
really because I first like what it
that's a lot of hand oh my god gold ones
I think they're showing off so many
different shops and what I loved partly
about this and so much of it is build-up
it's talking about the impending threat
or preparing for the first like seven or
eight minutes is all dialog it's all the
maintenance I like what she have a who
Dakota Fanning is something created in
order to serve a specific purpose like
she's not an alien but you know she's
some kind of society today yeah made up
in a labs in her service specific
purpose but it's one of those things
well by the time he wants her to survive
like no you have life it kind of in like
like it's kind of similar her role that
she was in the BMW short get in terms of
like you were created but and we know
now you really want to live your own
life and he said you're humans yeah like
they plucked you up like think about
like that's the thing too is like that
last drop of humanity in it and it
brings that nuts not like it has to
prophesize about it but it brings that
element in you're like oh man yeah yeah
you might not be that dials up the dregs
is like you might not be okay and it's
that much more important to us that you
succeed at this you know because you're
not and enhanced as all the other you
know exactly machines who don't have to
worry so much and the Jose actor it was
cool kind of minded me a little bit of
John birth oh yeah yeah I really I
really enjoyed him in this too I mean I
always I always he always leaves an
impression on me when he shows up you
know even chappie and I think he's in
Elysium too and then he's a walking dead
he always leaves an impression but this
I was like I bet
is really cool for a guy like him to be
able to leave this one now yeah that
unlocks the potential like I really
liked watching the both of them as
individuals and together yeah you know
and this was yeah I was invested in
everything you know about so I know you
guys probably hate me for saying this
but there's a specific scene in aliens
when Michael being teaches Ripley how to
use an assault how these a machine gun
and I thought I was think you know -
yeah yeah this this is like this was the
alien bill here - yeah well yeah my idea
and I wondered if you know when they get
in when she gets into that room later
with that like black figure on the devil
and there are all those icky bits and
pieces you know like I can see that
being transcribed into a more alien
world any others you know not that's
what these are about there is that
throughout of a man he could have nailed
it you know what I am I'm gonna kill
that it didn't kill the alien five is
actually after seeing this piece of work
right here even the beginning when it's
in like 98 people survivors - and I
really over the other number - Bulba
this is already probably it's close to
his bad in the beginning just like you
know watching this 20 minutes made me go
I could see a whole feature film of
watching the creature develop over time
having these all these people on there
98 people they're all getting killed off
those down to these last two people
she's the heroine and the story I really
I really dug this one a lot this one got
me like super excited I'm hoping this
becomes a feature film out of all of
them this is the one I really want to be
a feature well this was the one - were
where I the most was invested in the
journey of the characters yet like I
want you to live yeah this you know this
is the quickest I got invested into
characters yeah out of all of them this
was a lot of ones are like
world-building and hinting at all these
other things and then the third one was
know the sharlto copley was more like
fascinating and weird yeah it's sort of
a left turn a little brevity yeah you
know but this one was very immediate he
puts you into the emotional state of
these characters and you're feeling it
happens like you know I started like
yeah I'm great
word and because they combine like it I
think this is really good horror you
know because it combines dread yeah
suspends i-5 or intensity body horror
science fiction and yeah you know there
are things that you can look at and you
can say like oh yeah this is probably
inspired by that but it's also unique if
you don't things especially and
especially with that creature in and I
love I love any story that has a bigger
set up to its characters that the actors
know with the writer or director know
but they're not really telling the
audience but you know it's there you
know yeah I like the way that they've
been writing these you know for the most
part I mean there's some stuff you have
to explain I feel like a lot of sci-fi
and a lot of fantasy you know you get
excited about the world that you're
building so you want to tell everybody
about Abaddon really understand how cool
this is yes but sometimes it's that much
cooler when you're just catching it in
the way that P&O talked about yeah in
the moment I really like the trajectory
that they've gone on with these three
films each one has pulled me in a little
bit more and each one's been markedly
different while also having the earmarks
that you love from Neil Blomkamp and his
teams you know an aesthetic style in
their approach you know the first one is
desolate and hot and slumming and you
know that's a good way to jump in coming
out of stuff like district 9 in Chafee
and then you know the second one period
piece different vibe you know same
intensity level and now this one you
know is just desolate Snow contained two
people each one's been different and I'm
really enjoying this drew I like this is
exciting I keep saying it's exciting and
it is it is exciting they get I get
better they got to get better yeah you
know in terms of 1/2 ins I go you know
because the third one is a very
left-field fun one and it's much shorter
and you know like that one's kind of I'm
interested also to see where the short
form stuff goes because the the
infomercials are pretty zany the god
short had its own sort of odd kind of
quirky satirical humor sort of and they
all have Dredd laced throughout oh yeah
even the god one has an oddly great
quality tone was so mad yeah yeah
menacing gets so light-hearted and like
I like I like the Hobby on what I meant
this one's like well this man yeah this
was menacing this I think this might
have been the most just flat-out minion
hold on oh absolutely and that's the
thing I'm really enjoying the way this
anthology is unfolding because you know
the more this I see the more I feel like
you can go in a lot of director totally
I can see you know a kind of a broad
palette for the future yeah I'm super
stoked
yeah really happy somebody's doing a
heading like this especially now you
know it's going to be hard to do and mad
respect for what they're matter doing
yeah and my last this is the dream kind
of last aliens reference he had you know
his eyes were cut out Hicks he has to
wear a bandage over his eyes I won't
mind remember dick but I wonder if this
might have been this might as well yeah
I imagine it probably was somewhat tie
my books yeah and you know maybe given
us I bet that monsters a whole different
you know like how can we adapt no that's
a xenomorph the new one the dr. Morris
all right gel where can they watch all
this stuff again you can watch all this
stuff on the Oates studios YouTube
channel their Facebook page and if you
want to get a full experience get on
steam the steam platform they have all
the shorts you can watch for free and if
you want to get involved again it's only
$4.99 per at least the main shorts and
then you can get all the behind the
scenes and examples of content you can
play with it on your own you can get
involved and get creative and all that
stuff watch how Neill Blomkamp invested
all his money for something to be free
on the internet
amen worth it though I'm loving it I'm
loving it like they're interested in the
future yeah man this is this is really
cool yeah Italy cool I mean I brought I
don't care what you think of chappie
this this [ __ ] freaking offering ah yeah
we like chappie but this is like oh yeah
yeah this is especially now the thing
this one like this this hit the sweet oh
yeah
well guys make sure subscribe to note
studios you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
please to get notified every time one of
our videos is up he is - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram we have a real
reject Instagram you can follow now and
as always you can check out our
exclusive perks and
or that patreon.com slash the real
rejects much-loved neill blomkamp you're
awesome